la france a perdu là la guerre des
vaccins sanofi a raté la marche
donc à partir de là donc on est bien
quand on est bien obligé de faire avec
ce qu'on a
astrazeneca donc devait nous fournir
quand même une bonne partie des doses et
je ne m'étonne d'ailleurs qu'il n'y ait
pas des pénalités financières très
importantes sur ce laboratoire qui n'est
pas été prévu parce qu'elle a
manifestement on a on a des contrats qui
sont floues on n'a jamais pu savoir le
prix qu'on paye et les vaccins et donc à
partir de là je pense qu'il ya quand
même un problème de fond au niveau de la
commande maintenant astrazeneca donc
c'est un vaccin qui marche puisque
rappelons quand même que en deuxième
injection on dépasse les 85% d'immunité
et donc le rapport bénéfice risque et en
toute franchise très très bénéfique donc
il faut par contre que les aujourd'hui
les français reviennent à la vaccination
et c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui on a une
perte de confiance au temps des patients
sur astrazeneca
mais autant des médecins j'ai des
médecins qui vaccinent du diabète salle
libéraux de la façon dont ils sont
traités par le gouvernement donc
aujourd'hui la médecine libérale et
qu'elle est traitée de façon tout à fait
je vais dire diffamatoires quand même je
dire ce sont quand même les médecins
libéraux qui sont sur le terrain c'est
aujourd'hui qu'ils téléphonent à leurs
patients pour se faire vacciner
c'est eux qui téléphonent sur leur corps
médical pour les pour leur demander de
plus venir quand ils amputent dose et
cette semaine encore on nous avait
annoncé 3 millions de doses le lendemain
on attendait un million six de doses
300000 la semaine suivante 300000 la
semaine d'après et ont remonté un
million sept après les 3 millions je ne
sais pas où elles sont sur la semaine
voilà donc il ya quand même un problème
de transparence et surtout de confiance
aujourd'hui
la commission européenne a très mal
négocié avec des gens qui n'étaient pas
habilités ou compétents la seule hantise
des gens de la commission européenne ce
et je ne risque rien sans rien risquer
ainsi dans ce contrat donc on a mis un
temps infini pour pouvoir commander des
doses
israël les états unis au fond c'est pour
avoir des doses et après si vous voulez
aller directement sur août nique le
problème mais on va dire de spoutnik
c'est on n'a pas les données on va dire
officiel on va dire de la commission
mes parfums européenne de validation
mais surtout irréaliste ils n'ont pas de
capacités de production suffisantes donc
l'idée qui est très bonne
d'ailleurs la part de la russie c'est de
dire j'ai un vaccin qui marchent pas
problème on va le valider je pense qu'il
est bon mais ils n'ont pas de capacités
de fabrication sur sol français et ce
que disent elles filent vers vache est
très juste c'est que clairement on est
quand même le seul pays on va dire du
conseil heureux de ses revenus à ne pas
avoir une vaccination opérationnel sur
notre territoire
pourquoi parce qu'on est des
branquignols qu'ils ne choisissent leur
mauvaise adjuvant qui vont pas contrôle
de qualité guerre interne dans le
laboratoire et résultat on part sur une
technologie qui est ancienne la nouvelle
technologie c'est les vaccins arn
messagers la rsb s'agisse existe depuis
dix ans 12 en cancérologie
c'est l'immunothérapie donc les types
sont inadaptés mais bon la france a raté
le coche gabriella talent a dit la
semaine dernière qu'on s'adapte et au
virus
voilà mais en fait pour gérer une
pandémie comme ça il faut pas s'adapter
il faut la devancer il faut la
programmer et donc c'est pas en
s'adaptant si on s'adapte on a toujours
un train de retard
on est derrière voilà et dont c'est ce
que fait le bon produit il s'adapte mais
avec retard la fermeture des écoles
ça fait trois semaines qu'on la repousse
alors c'est vrai que chaque fois qu'il
ya un cas positif en faire on ferme une
classe mais ça veut dire que de toute
façon va fermer toutes les classes on
sait très bien que dans les collèges et
les lycées
c'est là où le taux de transmission est
le plus fort donc il faut fermer
rapidement et collèges et les lycées les
classes élémentaires c'est plus
compliqué parce qu'à ce moment là vous
mettez tous les gens à l'arrêt au niveau
du travail et donc c'est la mesures
auraient dû être prises déjà depuis un
bon moment et c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui
on est toujours en arrière et je présume
quand même que d'ici quelques mois en
faisant le constat qu'on sera encore les
bons derniers de la classe au niveau
mondial voilà on est dos au mur sur la
réalisation est on ne peut plus
bénéficier des transferts on va dire de
personnel qu'on l'a vécu lors des
premières mal parce que tout le monde
est épuisé
tout le monde est dans le rouge donc la
seule manière d'y arriver c'est de
pouvoir jouer way through combat mais ça
ça suppose une mesure très simple c'est
à dire l'obligation de transfert des
patients
or actuellement vous l'avez suffisent à
rendre dans
aux antennes une autre constatation
terrain il ya un refus des familles pour
ceux transférés alors moi je râle parce
qu'un passe temps qui va deux jours à
clermont ferrand c'est comme un pas
dramatique
dans les seuls maintenir de faire si
vous pouvez pas avoir la destination à
temps il faut être réaliste on les
emploie si les espagnols sont pas trop
respecté et il faut peut-être cela se
poser la question
c'est le troisième voyage c'est à dire
essayer de répartir au mieux de remplir
les trous dans la raquette et pour ça
faut aussi avoir rien dit c'est bon de
transfert il n'y a pas le choix sinon
effectivement une réponse et apprendre
une technique des majeures à séoul